there's a feeling about the bottom boys
in this city to this day even when it
was 20 years 30 years whatever it is
people still say there's never been a a
group of young men like it no
nothing
and then every time i say where i'm from
every time somebody say somebody's name
it'd be my bloodline if somebody's in my
family from there anybody's going to
listen to like man handling like
[Music]
just tell me who you are where you from
man
whack baby
richard wilson real name man yeah um
street poor louisiana
1100 block of fantasy street man right
in the heart of the heart of the heart
of the bible
grew up in whatever 1974
uh
2 31 p.m sprague street 110 block of
sprague street okay we live directly
across the street from the graveyard in
the graveyard it was infested with
spiders and scorpions and stuff and she
always told the story that a torrential
was crawling up her leg and she went
into labor with me wow yeah i heard the
crazy tarantulas in that graveyard yeah
crazy for real yeah
and how about you cart what's your name
man
yeah yeah where you from man
kill real i'm really i'm from manila
yeah i live in the bottom across the
track my dad from the bottom so
i ain't never just grow up throwing out
none of that
always
we throw your hand a little bang that's
one thing that's it you learned that huh
from a young age and what i learned just
for the purposes of uh our audience
who who's that to you man man that's my
heart yeah that's my heart that's um
that's a clean version of me
that's trying to find his own way
you know what i'm saying that's what
that is to me man he is the reason
that what i try to get him to understand
man or or or
um
consider
the sacrifices that i made to stay alive
and free
to make sure that um he didn't have to
deal with none of the [ __ ] that i had to
deal with
not knowing that
when he got older he still gotta
go through what he got to go through on
his own and for the most part man it'll
pretty much be some of the same [ __ ]
that i was tempted by coming from where
we come from yeah you know what i'm
saying it was gonna either be you gonna
be in the game or you're gonna be you
know what i'm saying how old were you
when you had your first son 16 my
daughter you're i was i was
she was born yeah i was 17. i remember
you told me
that
at one point the police were taking you
away
and they told you
that
you was never going to see your baby
again yeah
and the thought that you had
was you never really expected to make it
to 18
yeah because you know man when we when
our immature mind man um
an immature mind received any
[ __ ] thing that seems common to
them
you know what i'm saying so if you if if
80 of your friends didn't live or
didn't live to see 18 years old you know
what i'm saying then i would think that
okay that's my life in this life too so
i'm gonna live my life like i don't give
a [ __ ]
right now you know what i'm saying
because i know that it got a time limit
on it so i got so much i got to do in
that short
time but it didn't happen like that it
wasn't until i got older man
that i realized that you don't you don't
don't nothing happen in life
by chance
nothing happened by chance man
everything happens because it's supposed
to happen simple as that
would you say he's the cleaner version
of you yeah he's a cleaner version of me
because ricardo them can't even imagine
something that i hadn't done
growing up in the bottom like being for
real
and i compare it
with what they doing now you know what
i'm saying
but what he doing now not like a lot of
the youngsters they doing a lot of dumb
dumber [ __ ] than we was doing because
it's dumber because it's done without
respect for nobody else you know what
i'm saying
so when i compare my life to his at his
age
they ain't been through half of what i
hadn't been through
or had to try to survive you know what
i'm saying when you when when you were
coming up cardo you know we talked about
this a little bit just a minute ago
you know when you heard names like goat
band pops your uncle everybody who came
up before you all your all the different
dads in your life all them guys what was
your take what was your take on them to
me these dudes can't be touched you know
how you come up from someone is like
like you know how you growing up you got
your daddy right
to you your dad ain't no ain't nobody
from the beach your dad you know i'm
saying yo daddy
that he everything you know what i'm
saying it's like
hearing some stuff man it was just like
they couldn't be messed with it was like
i'm trying to i'm trying to word it
right
no i'm saying it's like i know that
there's a there's a feeling about the
bottom boys in this city to this day
even when it was 20 years 30 years
whatever it is people still say there's
never been a a group of young men like
it no i ain't nothing whatever nothing
even what you see many do they they go
they ain't have like they have those
people growing up or
raised around or heard those type of
names you know i'm saying like
i ain't grow up like a lot of them do
because i had him you know i'm saying i
was smarter even though i did my little
thing i always thought it out first not
saying i'm doing but man hearing them do
this like it's different like i can
ain't no no i'm saying
from there ain't nobody mess with you
like and then every time i say where i'm
from every time somebody say somebody's
name it'd be my bloodline no i'm saying
somebody's in my family you know i'm
saying is it like
you told me uh when you were a youngster
you were with them and that ended up
saving a few of their lives oh yeah he
told me who didn't call me at the time i
don't i don't remember who i was i know
[ __ ] leave for sure and big o i had
some
some well where i got some homeboys that
had an issue with each other but this
was like like it's it's like
when you leave from under that umbrella
you start living by different rules
you know what i'm saying so after the
hood got dismantled people started
living by different rules they started
doing stuff that we wouldn't do in the
bottom like
you would purposely want to take the
life of somebody else from the bottom
like wing wing rock like that that was
one of the number one things that we
didn't do so but then you had to think
about
who the guys was that actually did it
these guys that wasn't born and raised
down there so they didn't have the same
values that family values that we had
with each other so it was easy for him
to pull a gun on one of the
other homeboys you know what i'm saying
and um
just so happened the day that that
happened they had an altercation and the
day that they happened
he was in the car with him when they
pulled the guns on my other homeboy
and when they saw him
they fell back
when you got people like nowadays my
baby's getting killed bro maybe he's
getting babies
and then like
more babies getting killed than the
target you know what i'm saying for real
like he's like
i know if it's so overflow i can count
over four four five babies and got
killed or hit or sleep shot by but you
know what i'm saying
my family member included
for real
when you and me first met i've told you
this before
you know nobody's really influenced me
more about uh being a dad
than your dad you know your dad
has put your family
you know before him there's so many easy
paths and shortcuts you can take in life
you know what i mean and you your dad
has grinded with with with honor with
with grit and with love always putting
his family first
and you know when we first met it was
right
when i had a little baby probably
younger than your baby and i had another
one on the way
and your dad i asked him because you
know i'm mixed up you know the thing
about being a dad what you're seeing
right now
is
you love that baby so much and you just
that you there's nothing like it you
want every and i know your heart man
i've known you since you were a baby you
know what i'm saying and i've seen what
your dad you know what he pours into
that family and i asked him
because i was feeling a certain kind of
weight because i'm on the road so much
and and i said you know how i want to be
the best father in the world and your
dad just said to me man he said you know
you want to be a good dad all that [ __ ]
that you don't want your kid to be doing
all that [ __ ] that you know that's wrong
just stop doing it yourself just be that
model you know what i mean all that [ __ ]
and it really it's like it sounds simple
but it's everything it's like having
integrity you know not lying not
exaggerating not embellishing not you
know speaking ill about people being
positive working hard you know it's like
all them things like if you want your
kid to just start doing and that i'm
telling you that advice that you gave me
that was the day i met you it changed my
life man it changed my life i guess
maybe just give a um
an overview man of of uh what kind of
happened in the bottoms what happened to
your community you know you were one of
the only people who didn't get locked up
in that raid for the people who don't
know there was an entire community that
got taken down by the federal government
a historic thriving one of the most
you know beautiful communities that was
you know ever in the state of louisiana
historic you know just give that sort of
story and just tell about the community
about coming out in there and what that
was for you i um
up until the event happened i think that
was september the 14th was the september
14 1994
1994
that day we all went to jail man i can
remember when the people came they um
they took each and every last one of us
away in a separate car
and it was like a small and if i guess
because i was one of the younger ones
the guy that was in the back car
backseat with me
he felt like he could penetrate me as a
youngster like hey man look you know you
got your whole life ahead of you blah
blah blah dude you got any kids you'll
never see them play baseball and
growing up man like the police was like
the number one enemy like dude you knew
not to talk to the police about nothing
if they got you they got you whatever
they gonna deal with you would let them
deal with you with it you know what i'm
saying you know the ultimate rule you
know what i'm saying
and so that's what it was with me man
but
that's what bam said what he said the
other day he said man spiritually he
said i gravitate towards richard man i
said because that'll leave me the right
way
and so i look at everything and try to
look at everything in a spiritual light
and i walk in that light
versus going the wrong way after
everything happened we go down there
uh they pressed me about bam volley troy
they see they couldn't break me i'm like
man look whatever whatever you know what
i'm saying whatever y'all got me on deal
with me on that that was that but the
whole thing with me being out was was to
me like god keeping that candle lit
you know what i'm saying like i was the
last one left so okay
that fire
what's going on right now had to grow
from that [ __ ]
that that that small spark basically
you're in a situation where every man in
your life every uncle everybody you know
everybody else is going away for life
everybody was gone yeah and i was the
only one there man and um
at first i couldn't cope
ricardo came
a couple years after he came in 97 we
got he came three years after that so
when i i couldn't cope i went crazy
running around doing dumb [ __ ] robbing
people
um
and then one night i ended up getting
shot
and everything changed i got shot in the
head i got shot in his stomach mistaken
identity i wasn't even wild then but
that night changed my life because i
wanted to live to be there for him he
was four months old
and um
i i i got through that got myself back
together ended up going to jail did like
a a few months in jail and um
got my head in the game man and i came
back out and i started doing positive
stuff and i started connecting the
people that was coming home to people
that i was connected to on the outside
so that they wouldn't have to go back
down none of them same road
yep
when when you said you wanted to uh you
wanted to live because of him take me
through that
i i knew that if i didn't die in the
bottom that it was more to it than just
that and then i knew that
i had to be around for them dudes that
was gone
i had to be around man because they was
always there for me
you know what i'm saying yeah i had to
be there
yep when you look at your family now
what do you want for them like what do
you want for them
i just want them to understand the
sacrifices man that i had made as a
father versus
what what was coming in the hood you
know what i'm saying 80 90 of the dude's
not there when was the first time you
know you sort of came face to face with
j just sort of the ills that kind of
have plagued this city for a long time
like i remember when i was like when i
was real little
when we stayed on clay street i would
walk with my mama and this was it like
down the street
i remember seeing some [ __ ] having to
shoot all like right in front of us not
having nothing to do with him but this
is
it was just something i've seen like
they having a real life shootout like a
drive-by like the shootout back and
forth you know what i'm saying did that
scare you
no no i like i don't know i just
remember like watching i mean my mama
grabbing me you know saying we getting
down running back to the house like you
know what i'm saying but it was just
some probably just a regular it happened
all the time of it
you know i'm saying
it's a regular day but
with them like my daddy like
he always been a hustler like he's
saying like
he went a different path like he could
have like fought with the dope and like
this i didn't heard stories count
millions of dollars off cocaine you know
i'm saying like dude that i see now like
in the room we in the room at nine i
just like
hey i used to have millions you heard me
like
but he took a different route no i'm
saying like you say when he told me that
story like you know he got shot in the
head that same night you guys shot in
here you coming to see me as a baby are
you looking at yourself in the mirror
blood and stuff around you you know that
made me feel real special no i'm saying
but
i didn't heard a lot of it like hearing
stories man he's like watching some of
these movies now they know what i'm
saying here say that again like hearing
the stories i didn't heard like watching
like
like the movies and show the series that
they be doing like
it's like i it's like i lived through
that when i was young but i don't
remember so much about all i got now is
the people that i was around the baby
yeah the dead on life in jail you know
what i'm saying but like that night
you're saying when he was looking in the
mirror after he got shot in the head and
he went to come see you i don't remember
that but like but you touch that story
no i'm saying but there's never been a
day in your life that you haven't felt
loved
not ultimately not even just about him
that like even when he was gone like it
was love like my mama even tell me story
like how dude you would come by like
from jail just checking on us making
sure we straight we're good and nobody
mess with us and it was like
we're good like it was like like some
mob types it was untouchable no i'm
saying it was it was crazy but like
i just seen i ain't never just seen my
dad a while out you know what i'm saying
like he tried to keep up from there
because you know
if i seen i'm going to do it you know i
think the dude like he took a big toll
on me like like i said he just
bankrolls the money no i'm saying women
you know i just seen guns big choppers
all of it but i ain't never just seen
him like that and heard stories of my
uncles and what they even did but he
always if anybody can tell you like dude
i'm hanging around with now they they
salute me and they know
that
it's like i'm like he said i'm a cleaner
version like
i'm smart like the way i move they know
i ain't they know he been in my ill like
no i'm saying i get a lot of a lot of my
my sweetness from him you know what i'm
saying
i do my thing but
you know
it's just like
a lot a lot of stuff man because of him
like i get a lot of my ways from him but
you know i just think that you know man
something we talked about it's like my
little ones are still young man it's
like at a certain point it's like you
know it's just that's it we live for
them and and we
you know it's just so scary kind of like
what's out there and and how the world's
changing
what what are you most afraid of with
you with your babies
following the path of somebody else and
not their own because i know what i
instilled in them and that's leadership
you know what i'm saying
um
never let nobody man pick a treat for
you stand up under
because at the end of the day
every tell them to sit on his own bottom
you know what i'm saying yeah whatever
it is you do own up to it
whatever it is you choose to do man in
this life um
as a as a job a perfection or whatever
max that [ __ ] out yeah
you know what i'm saying i still live my
life the same i don't do nothing in
front of my kids that i'm not cool with
them picking up on yeah you know what
i'm saying yeah
i always tell ricardo i said man
i um
right now man if i chose to get in the
drug game i feel like i could be one of
the best drug dealers ever because i got
so much
knowledge on this game
but
i would win but i would ultimately lose
because that game is designed for you to
lose what percentage of the people do
you know that you [ __ ] with that that
have been shot
i gotta say 80. eighty percent of the
people right that's certain everybody
around everybody in that room in there
yeah
everybody in that room and they're just
about them being shot guaranteed if
that's the reality after everything
you've seen
is there any way in that game in your
opinion that doesn't have a bad ending
no none of you playing wrong that's what
i realized man the only way you i i
always tell people man you know how i
know um
doing the right thing works because i've
tried all the wrong [ __ ] yeah yeah it
just don't work
it just don't work man and you get what
you put out in life bro
simple as that man that's that's what i
believe yo cardo and me you know we like
i know how i know how talented you are
and i know your passion i know what you
want to do for that baby and i know but
but it's also i you know we were talking
the other day
right now it's hard man it's like you
got to provide
and
like what like how do you
how do you manage that like i understand
you have to do what you have to do and
you have to provide legitimately right
now if you're just going to get a job
what's that going to do for you
i mean
if i
it's like me getting like a job they
don't know what to take it'll take more
time with my little girl but i know at
the same time it's putting me in a
position to provide for me like i ain't
long on my way taking care of business
ignorance and to make sure she's
straight
you know i say i'm good but like
right now the way things looking is just
i'm shooting out all barrels like cause
i gotta get it but you know what i'm
saying is it i'm not just providing for
her right now no i'm saying
i'm
i'm just i got sisters i got a mom i got
myself that i ain't even always situated
with what i'm saying so it's like
it's it's real big on my plate but it's
like i know how to do i know what i got
to do
you know what i'm saying
get it done
do you think that i mean do do you agree
with what he said that that um that if
you're in that
life that it only ends so definitely
because i always
he always told me it's not man i heard
this since all he he told me since i was
little
and i'm 25 now and it's still with me
like he always told me like
he know i like money you know what i'm
saying
and it's like
as long as i'm doing a bad thing with
the money it's not gonna last no i'm
saying
was right with them when the money is
gonna last no i'm saying
what i always try to instill in them was
man
never put money before people
you know what i'm saying
never put the money before the people
man no you know what i'm saying and
never put yourself in a situation
that'll jeopardize your life or your
freedom for no money [ __ ] it
pick the right product run it up you
ain't got to worry about that
and and i mean that's really what you
did that's simple simple as that i chose
the right product you know what i'm
saying i chose a different product that
don't come with the [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying and
not only that but that's hard i mean you
grinded like a [ __ ] to i was
able to deal with that [ __ ] the same way
i would deal with with anything else you
know what i'm saying that was illegal
you know what i'm saying
look man it's just like for me and from
where i sit it's just like you have to
acknowledge
you know like i see a world and i live
in a world now where your average child
just
seen drive-by shootings on a regular not
i mean how many friends have you lost
from gun violence
like my my real like all of my real
friends you know like my that i grew up
in the neighborhood with
dead or in jail like my partners that i
called partners i went to school with
them like i didn't just see them on the
regular like they go home at the end of
the day or they might as i got older you
know mom let you come over after school
you know i'm saying we kick it you know
what i'm saying but
my friends in the neighborhood man they
did or in jail like my partner used to
come spend life with me in elementary
from lehigh
in my neighborhood in jail
uh with ricardo a whole lot faster than
it did with me with me growing up in a
heavier populated area you would think
that i would witness that more than he
would but he actually witnessed that
[ __ ]
well because you had the bot you had
everybody around you it was
everybody looked out for it's just it's
just different now right i mean that's
what i guess
you know man i know you know this but
you know every time you know me me and
him talk all the time and every time he
calls he's telling me what's going on
you know as far as the way y'all
communicate is the way you all
communicate but you are always you know
front and center same way i'm with my
boys like you are front and center on
this dude's mind hey this hap this
little boy got shot you need to talk to
your nephew you know like this and you
know and and i guess you know for me i'm
just sitting here knowing
that look man i've known you since
you're a little boy and i love you man
like you you don't you don't realize how
much you know i think about you and and
the idea something happened to you man
where you were born and where you were
born
you didn't get the same breaks that a
lot of kids in this country get you know
what i'm saying but that being said
you got some like you you you know what
you have you know like and you don't you
know he didn't have what you have you
know what i'm saying i want to be honest
without him i don't know i don't i just
don't know where we would have been no
i'm saying to be honest with you say
that again without him i don't know what
he would have been like if he would have
died that night like i don't know how it
would have turned out yeah yeah no i'm
saying i know
i would have grew up with his ways but i
don't know which ways i would have
turned out that's what i'm saying that's
right
but i guess it's like i feel like you
know you you know you're in this
situation which i know you can empathize
with he's in this situation right now
where he's got to you know he's got to
provide yeah and you know it's like and
you know i mean it's like you you ain't
blind to it you know what i mean like
you know what you got to do today
he um that's the thing man i it took me
some getting used to
saying you know what man
you grown
you're gonna make your own decisions at
the end of the day and i came a lot i i
remember when i remember when i right
before i got shot john i was burned up
real bad in a car accident something
happened but
um my mama showed so much concern the
night that i got shot
but i mean the night that i got burned
but the night that i got shot she's so
less concerned and i think in between
the time me getting burned and shot
she made a decision to say you know what
you've grown and i can't let the way you
live and
cause me no health problems yeah simple
as that yeah you know what i'm saying
it's like i love you
but
i love me too yeah and i got i got other
people i got to be there for yeah so
that's where i met with my kids man
that's that's my hard [ __ ] man you know
what i'm saying when
you see your kids moving a certain way
and you know what's going on and they
running with different [ __ ]
that you don't know you know it's like
i'm blind with a lot of soul yeah if me
as a here you know i know
it'll take for him to get older to
understand when his daughter started
doing [ __ ] for him not like damn that's
what daddy was talking about yeah but
i'll tell you i mean carter you know man
he's like you got a big ass heart man
he's more he's wise as all hell and i
mean like i know where your heart is
with that little girl man yeah you know
what i'm saying i know she's everything
and you know
but i also i just like you know if
anything you know like what we're trying
to do here it's just
it's a predicament man it's like i'm not
trying to come at you or preach at you
like it's a tough situation man that's
why like
man i it let me to be tough cause like
it's so much holding you back when you
know your attention on what you want to
do no i'm saying it's like
man that's one of my biggest i do not
want my little girl
to grow up here to be doing the same
thing her mama doing just working y'all
the job
break getting heartbroken by different
dudes you know like this it's more to
that than him going to the club the same
club every weekend and stuff like that
man ain't
ain't nothing popping now it's nothing
like i won't i won't i really want
different for what i'm saying yeah and
so it's that same thing right i mean the
only thing we just said in the car
coming back right you can't change
people in this world you know i mean you
can only change yourself you change
yourself you change the world you know
what i'm saying
and and uh you know i just think that
that's kind of it i i like tell me a
little bit carter like now you got a
murder rate in this city that's the
highest
i guess it just hit the record last
night yeah so i mean now it's actually
you know more dangerous out here than
than when he was on the streets do you
feel that do you feel that every day
yeah yeah like they know i ain't going
nowhere without my gun
straight up nowhere
i got it with me now i ain't going
nowhere without it
this is because he ain't got to be on
that type of time it's just
people just eating like i got a partner
just kill somebody
he and he walking free but it's like
he said when i when i ran it with him he
was like people so crazy bro he only
like talking about because he tried to
fuel the situation you know i'm saying
like
dude is still hot-headed about the
situation when he trying he not knowing
that he got his kids and wife in the car
no i'm saying
and he got dude still trying to get
everyone you trying to resolve something
one thing go to no no i'm saying and
it's just like that like it could just
be it'd be anything it's just nowadays
it's people you feel every day like do
you ask yourself every day
i don't like
i know like nothing coming toward me but
i don't want to be one of the people
that
at the wrong place wrong time i don't
know what i'm saying
it's like that you know i'm saying like
i had just pulled off
just from literally in front of one of
my partners before he just got shot in
the head
i was just i had just pulled down and
you said they came at your block like
like the like two times when you
yeah
yeah i remember one time
and a baby got killed this night
my little sister had just graduated high
school we had a high school graduation
for
some of the dude coming down the street
just you know i gotta say normal shoot
like some car shooting back to back you
know i'm saying we but we hear bullets
and knowing that we think the people
shooting at us no i'm saying but it's
not even wasn't even like that you just
you got everybody running and ducking
all the time you got people running
around shooting you know what i'm saying
you it's just
you never know man you never know
you might have seen somebody you you
been on a different time
you never know how somebody might be
feeling someday you know i'm saying
you think i mean like look man like
right now we like sitting here right and
upstairs i don't know what there's 20
people up there and lesbians like we
ain't naming any names because nobody
can see who's up there right now but
we're there there's killers here right
like there's there's people who've had
to kill right if you are like living in
that right in that reality
day in and day out if you're living
around that all the time that that
hardening is is real or do you think
there's still some [ __ ] you haven't
dealt with and it's you still get scared
you still get upset you're still hurting
like does that go i think it's possible
for somebody to become numb with it
especially um
somebody like ricardo
if you grow up in that [ __ ] and um
you never get a chance to really uh
suffer the consequences or none of that
[ __ ] you would feel invincible and you
would keep going you know what i'm
saying you will become numb to all of
that [ __ ] you think it's just normal
life yeah and that's how you can get
hurt that's one of my biggest fears
becoming numb to what's going on in this
city that mean that i would go to any
[ __ ] gas station unaware uh
i'm not paying attention none of that
[ __ ]
but i always stay on point at all times
and i think a lot of people get hurt man
because they become numb to
thinking that it won't happen in certain
spots or
with certain people you know what i'm
saying
yeah
what's the kind of fear that you live
with every day
one of my biggest fears is not knowing
the exact people that my kids deal with
you know what i'm saying
because for every one person you deal
with
i always say with me man the people that
come around me
every time somebody come around me i
take on everything that they dealing
with
because if somebody looking for them and
they want them bad enough they don't
give a [ __ ] about me or nobody else
you know what i'm saying so i have to
monitor who come in my circle and if you
do come in my circle i like to know
exactly what's going on with you
you know what i'm saying i'll be a whole
lot more comfortable if i knew exactly
what was going on with you if you come
in my circle i know you got beef or
somebody else then
it ain't gonna sit right with me yeah
because i'ma feel like it's some danger
not just to me but to everybody else
that's around me mm-hmm you know what
i'm saying
yeah
i mean do you think do you think your
future's here in shreveport
hell no you know the answer liquid yeah
i mean like
it could
it could be you know i'm saying it could
be like
i don't know is it no i don't even just
see no future history i've been our
group street football a long time ago
ain't nobody enjoying it i think like
it's
everything out of like depression you
know i'm saying people it's like
everybody got problems you know i'm
saying and
people that's any like a youngster like
us you got
is baby mama drama you're losing
partners you see every day you know what
i'm saying
you got
it it's just
everybody want not everybody want money
for everybody struggling you know i'm
saying you got it
i don't know man it's really wild right
now it's just really wild right now i
think there's a misconception man i
think people
i think people often feel like people in
that life in this country who have no
idea what that is no idea the
predicament that there is no idea the
lack of options or whatever options are
open to them i think that they think
that they're just taking the easy way
out or they're being selfish when i
think that the majority of folks who are
actually in that life are doing it
because they're trying to put food on it
like the big like
a lot of like
people like y'all so they feel like grow
up like me you got probably like a
handful of that
really scene or really come from my
family like that they really want out
you know i'm saying a lot of them just
doing it for the image you know i'm
saying like
and then ain't
that's why a lot of beef going on
because half do you do know they do not
living like that you know i'm saying
when somebody turned up hurt every time
i turn to her they go ah he was a good
kid he wasn't doing that there and
they don't know that he outside doing
this no i'm saying
it's all kind of it's like you don't
have too many of them just
really trying to get the money and
provide you heard i mean you don't got
two minutes trying to do it they they
want an emmy they want the image of
somebody not messing with them and no
one known for having money you know what
i said and
and because you think why that's the bet
like
that's what's going to get you the most
ladies that's what's going to get you
the most you know respect and that ain't
what the main response i think is the
stage we set for them for the most part
you know what i'm saying because we was
on the streets making money just to kind
of really pretty much shine on each
other you know same story shoes clothes
money clothes hoe same thing and nobody
really had a real plan with the money
that they was putting that they were
sacrificing their life my thing is if
i'm gonna sacrifice my life man for some
money i'm gonna get that [ __ ] and do
something with it that i know
you know what i'm saying can't nobody
take from me
simple as that that's the name of the
game
you know what i'm saying and
back in the days you used to be able to
get in the game and get you enough to
get you something positive going
but it's so cutthroat now man it's like
i don't get it i just don't get it man
and which is one of my biggest things
with with any of my homeboys when they
come home i'm always trying to help
these dudes get jobs because i know what
it is
you know what i'm saying
the same thing yield the same results
man simple as it you got you want to see
something different you got to do some
different do something different you got
to do something different and you can't
be afraid to do
some [ __ ] that may be in your mind that
you always wanted to try you just can't
be afraid to do it man
life and everything in it people
included is temporary yeah
you know what i'm saying and you just
got to do what you got to do while
you're here man yeah and be the best
person you can be and help as many
people as you can help that's it simple
as that man are you much different than
the dude you were when when you were his
age or when you were younger i am
because i was more i listen more i'ma
say that because i listen to
positivity more i used to sit around
like a lot of older cats man that own
businesses
and
i couldn't tell him that he didn't know
what the [ __ ] he was talking about
because he running a business
you know what i'm saying and i knew that
okay
if i got 90 of the dudes in the
neighborhood man that's doing the wrong
thing and i'm watching what's happening
to them
and then i got a cat over here that got
a barber shop
all of the cats that's doing the wrong
thing they dying going to jail but this
cat over here still
got his barbershop going so apparently
he's doing something right yeah yeah you
know what i'm saying yeah
yeah
what's what's your perfect situation
five years from now you're 28
28 years old
how you see yourself man
you ever think about that
i ain't like man it'd be too much to go
like
it's too much going on right this second
right yeah so just [ __ ] with that for a
second yeah so like if i would though
like just like me just imagine you know
what i'm saying myself
man it's really to feel stable you know
i'm saying just to feel like a house car
my baby's straight you know what i'm
saying nice little business going my
barber shop no i'm saying
still doing me you know i'm saying it's
like that's
five years from now yo this but
five years from now man it's like a snap
of a finger though and you got so much
going on right now man still easy to get
caught up in
not saying what's going on it's and then
then again now it's all on you
it's really all on you
every step you take is closer to that
five years it's just how it is just what
direction you take that step right
it's like this is a mindset thing it's a
mindset thing but you know
sorry go ahead you don't have like
i don't know bro you know like it'd be
so much
so much going on especially like when
you're struggling so much going on a day
to think about five years from now yeah
i said you can see you can say like when
even when you are scrolling you might
sit and think about it for one day but
you gotta really like be dedicated on to
get the you know i'm saying
what would you want for him five years
from now
to be stable mentally not um
for him to know exactly what it is that
he want to do you know what i'm saying
and to be perfecting that alone you know
what i'm saying not jeopardizing that
[ __ ]
you know what i'm saying
my thing with ricardo is
you're a certified barber man either you
could be a certified barber out here and
make all the [ __ ] money you want to
make and i guarantee you that if you did
go to jail you're still gonna be a
[ __ ] barber
because that's that's what's in your
heart
you know what i'm saying
so
and the same thing with me man like i
got a passion for food now if i do some
dumb [ __ ] i know that i'll be
in jail serving food
you know what i'm saying you got to
latch onto [ __ ] that they can't take
away from you exactly got a latch on it
in this world exactly you know what i
mean that's the whole key if i can
create some [ __ ] that they can't take
that's it you know what i'm saying and i
know that they want to take it
so this [ __ ] really is chess i gotta
play
by they rules man you know what i'm
saying but not by the rules yeah you
feel me
and acknowledging the fact that that you
know some of this [ __ ] is just [ __ ]
unfair man it is it's like the game is
just [ __ ] unfair it is but you can
either say hey man [ __ ] this game it's
unfair i learned how to [ __ ] play it
even even with me with the food john if
you can remember man when i first
started i started out cooking at home in
the backyard yeah my [ __ ] police
showed up all the time
all because
me selling food that way was unregulated
and i wasn't paying the state the taxes
none of that [ __ ]
right but
when i when i really got off into it and
i became legal i understood what was uh
um a regulated piece of uh uh
what was a regulated food truck you know
what i'm saying like the trailer that i
got in the back back there i i don't
supposed to be able to take that out on
the streets and sell food off of it
because it's not enclosed none of that
[ __ ]
now y'all gave me hell when i was in my
backyard doing it but i got
[ __ ] with unregulated trailers
on main intersections in the city and
nobody's saying nothing
you see what i'm saying it's all because
they get favoritism from certain people
you know what i'm saying it's a lot of
fun you've been dealing with that your
whole life man it's crazy it's it's
crazy bro
but if i wasn't making it if i was in
the backyard man
selling five six places a day nobody
would never say [ __ ] but how many people
in that same situation once it gets off
the backyard we're saying man [ __ ] this
[ __ ] this is some [ __ ] they coming
after me i'm done with all this
i met a guy man when i first became
legal in the food business he told me
getting legal was one of the worst
things he ever done
because of the consequences
and i thought about it
you know what i'm saying
the consequences ain't nothing
[ __ ] been cooking out of the
house forever but once you become legal
you have um
you got responsibilities now you got to
pay these taxes
you got to get them that bread you know
what i'm saying you got to play by the
book yeah
yeah in that field you could buck the
system and nothing really never happened
unless you get a restaurant
or some [ __ ] like that you know what i'm
saying
but i could have done it out of my house
forever yeah yeah i mean it was worth it
nothing never could have been done but
what that would have did is it wouldn't
allow me to take my [ __ ] to the next
level you got anything that you y'all
want to say to each
other no i'm i'm well made with ricardo
man and the rest of my kids that's grown
i'm i'm staying in prayer for a man and
the thing i did instill in them was
a strong prayer life
i think ricardo called me one time he
was going through something he was like
daddy i need you to pray for him i'm
like why pray for yourself you come on
man you know him
you know what i'm saying that's when you
run to god the most man when you got
issues
don't never feel like it's nothing you
doing or done dead to where he can't
hear you but it's all about the
sincerity of it what is that carter what
what's god to you
shh
faith
really no saying he's
you don't see him no i'm saying you
talking to somebody you don't see all
day you're going through all these
problems you know i'm saying like he be
on me all the time but what i do is like
i i thought i listened bro i always he
always told me this like even if you
heard it before no i'm saying don't just
still listen you know what i'm saying
there's one thing about me i listen but
one thing bro uh
i'm good at practicing because i'm real
like i try not to care about
irrelevant things but like
certain thing that i know like far as
jeopardizing my life and still man i'm
always strong on my faith no i'm saying
because i know
he know my heart you know i'm saying
like
whatever i'm doing man
i can't hang on let me go down like that
if you do is listen learn not saying
whatever help him help him no i'm saying
but my faith man this that's what he is
to me you know what i'm saying
you know man your heart man you know
you know just like what i said from the
beginning man you know i love y'all man
you know the wilson's is a beautiful
family man and and you know i'm i'm a
better better human being you know and a
better artist a better father better man
because cause because i i know y'all you
know i mean and we got to be connected
forever you know what i'm saying so i
just appreciate i appreciate we had this
little
you know moment yeah i taught my kids
man that um
i believed in everything that is to
possibly believe in man the guns the
dope the homeboys all of it and all of
that [ __ ] failed me
but
when i put my when i was in a situation
a life or death situation man and i
cried out to this person that i
you know heard was god and this is what
he'll do and he brought me out of it in
every other situation that i'd have been
in he got up and i was like damn yeah
this this work
man nothing else works so you gotta in
life where you gotta believe in
something
straight up man and that's the thing
that i i don't push it on nobody but
that's what worked for me and so that's
what i instilled in my kids now when
they got older
they was like i said they were gonna
choose their own path
and with ricardo
and and my other grown kids i know that
what i instilled in them will come back
around regardless if i see that [ __ ]
right now in them
it's in there it'll come back around
they just gotta keep living you know
what i'm saying
so my job is to keep them covered in
prayer man and um
let them live their life yeah you know
what i'm saying man me and my wife we
had a um it's something happened where a
few people got killed in the city here
not long ago a male had a convict matter
of fact it was one of his one of his
friends got killed all day like one day
and oh
man his mom had a talk i was like i
caught her doing because i know him in
the dude they was big jam and she was
like well you know you sometimes you got
to let him bump his head on his own and
i was like well
from a father's point of view i don't
think that's wise in this world because
when i was coming up
bump your head means you got a chance to
do that [ __ ] again in this world bump
your head means death
so whatever i gotta say to his ass i'ma
say it now i ain't gonna wait would you
say whether he like it or not what did
you say so my thing with him was
man choose carefully the guys that you
have around you man the little guy that
got killed he was a good dude but he was
around the wrong people
you know what i'm saying and that [ __ ]
could happen to anybody and with ricardo
ricardo pretty much like me man i feel
like i grew up a maid man because
i'd done a lot of [ __ ] because i knew i
could get away with it or if somebody
wanted to do something to me they had to
go through other people to get to me
you know what i'm saying and the people
that they had to go through to get to me
you don't want to go through those you
don't want to go to the people so it
allowed me to do a lot of dumb ass [ __ ]
that jeopardized the whole lot thank god
that nothing did happen yeah you know i
ain't never really been like that ain't
never really
he ain't never been like that but
whether he want to be or not
he is who he is it's like a made man
like
whether you want a [ __ ] to
respect you because of who i am as a
person you can't control that that's
just what that is
you know what i'm saying and to be
honest with you i would rather had it
you know what i'm saying i would rather
have that because a lot of people don't
got that
you feel me hundred percent a lot of
[ __ ] going back
like like he's saying like i ain't
i like i got my own bloodline like
[ __ ] come at me and be like man you
think you would cause you man never
anytime i ever flex my muscle bra i know
what you know i'm saying what the
outcome of stuff would be but i ain't
never i know i'm jeopardizing them i'm
bringing them out they ain't never did
it because i like i just i just know but
like
i need to know now people know like hey
but that ain't nothing i want to do
because it can turn out bad you know i'm
saying and
you like i say like shh
i don't be want to jump without them at
night man yeah that's one of the things
that kind of tied my hands behind my
back because i would always think like
okay well
i know some dudes that's gonna come out
there for me whether i'm right or wrong
and this whole [ __ ] gonna be bad
like some people gonna get hurt so i
would have to make a conscious decision
to say you know what
it wouldn't be wise for me to [ __ ] with
it because then
i got people man
that you know i'm saying
like i got a cousin man that got killed
he was one of them type people man to
where
if if if he met you and he get and he
like you
you could walk away from him go down the
street and get in tour with somebody and
come back and he he like hey man what's
going on with you
oh we need to handle this right now
you know what i'm saying
so i would have to make a decision
for them
and to swallow [ __ ] and not get in and
should walk away from you gotta turn the
other cheek man and it it was simply for
other people because i know this whole
[ __ ] gonna turn out bad yeah yeah you
know what i'm saying yeah and so when
you kind of like got the maid man thing
going on man you got to be real
careful because like even with what i do
today i got a lot of dudes that come to
me and like hey man you you need me
you know what i'm saying yeah i know and
i'm like i'm good yeah
yeah i would rather talk a dude down
from hurting somebody than a taco dude
into hurting somebody simple as that man
that's just the love i got for people
and i feel like i'll live longer and i
go a long way man being like that
you know what i'm saying john i know
exactly that's the [ __ ] that make me
feel good man
when i could see
the decision you made actually kept
somebody all right or amazing i mean
that
man in the in the streets a lot of
people be like oh man you ain't with
that no i'm not with it
you know what i'm saying we've been
losing for too [ __ ] long though
somebody got to be smart about this yeah
at the end of the day it's about
survival right
and then we got these youngsters
watching us
whatever we do they gonna do
it'll just be a vicious cycle that'll
keep going so if somebody don't try to
at least fix some of the [ __ ] that we
done
they they [ __ ]
so what i instilled in ricardo hopefully
he'll instill that [ __ ] in the ones
that's coming behind them
you know what i'm saying
yeah
i know everything happens for a reason
you know what i'm saying and um
yeah man
you're family now like that's that
that's family man for real yeah it ain't
too many people at you
even when i can remember i don't know if
you remember but i can remember when you
went to do fury he was like man okay i'm
going to i'm going to europe we finna do
this move with phil i'm going to talk to
brad pitt about the whole project yeah
yeah how long ago that's been
man that was
[ __ ] man like eight years ago or some
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying and it's
like it went from
it went from that interview that day
that we had over there yeah
to like hey man
yeah
that's that's family man for real that
first time we met man yeah in the back
of sean's house
what's up
i appreciate y'all man i love y'all
[Music]
thanks for being here everybody i really
appreciate it if you dug what you saw
and you want to hear more subscribe like
do all that stuff uh it'd mean a lot to
us i hope you dig these episodes as much
as we dig doing them you guys take care
of yourself